hey there bonus thanks for tuning in
today I'm going to be speaking to you
about social nootropics can a supplement
make you more charismatic charming and
confident nope no it cannot
but it's interesting and some people
think that they can so let's have a look
at some of those nootropics those social
neutral picks and see how they're
alleged to work whether or not they do
work and some interesting ideas around
that subject
so a lot of people who become interested
in the subject of nootropics do say
because they saw the film limitless the
film where the guy takes the pill NZT
and he just becomes fast smarter he's
much more witty in conversation he
writes a novel in record time and he
stuffs trading day trading and becomes
very wealthy and he manages to pull lots
of women because he's so charismatic and
he goes with lots of cool holidays and
moves into a massive flat and basically
lives the dream and that's why people
get into new trade books often because
they see that film and this TV series as
well see which is very good and they
think hey man I want to be like that is
that really a pill that can do that and
then you look up online and they see it
there's lots of nootropics out there I'm
adapt and they'll harass the town things
like that the claim to make you smarter
and clever and they're like lady this is
the same kind of thing and apparently
one percenters are using these sorts of
things what that means your guess is as
good as mine but basically a lot of the
top-performing
executives entrepreneurs CEOs they claim
that they use modafinil or something
similar in order to get to where they
get so then people take these new trade
picks and they find that their lives
don't change they don't write any
bestselling novels they don't become a
whiz at the stock market and in fact all
that happens is maybe they feel a little
less tired and so it's not exactly like
a super a transformation like it is in
limitless it's more like hey I'm a
little bit less tired man so new
trimmers don't really tend to do that
sorting and they might look into brain
training like the dual n-back test and
they'll find hey I can improve my
working memory by you know one digit and
my IQ by like two digits and it doesn't
really change their lives so the idea of
station Newton makes is very interesting
because these are new topics that are
all about improving your ability to
interact with other people you're going
more charismatic and more engaging when
you speak and that sort of thing
actually would have a much bigger impact
on your life then something like trying
to be slightly better at memorizing long
sequence of numbers because in the real
world we don't tend to need to memorize
long sequences of numbers or random
lists of items in the real world a lot
of our success comes from our
interactions with other people and if
you can sound more confident if you can
walk with a kind of air you know the law
of attraction all that stuff then things
do start to come to you so people are
kind of looking down on the wrong road
when they're so interested in improving
their working memory or their IQ
slightly if they're really interested in
being 16 a successful slick person that
they weren't before then the sixth one
that social nootropic in theory would be
more kind of the sort of thing they'd be
looking for whether or not you'd really
want to change your person after that
that's a whole different issue I'd say
probably not but that's something for
another time and there are some people
who are using social neutral things it's
not very popular term I managed to get
the number one spot on Google for social
nootropics so obviously it's not
something that lazy people are writing
about but it is something that some
people are using they use social
nootropics mainly to combat social
anxiety these are people who are not
fine
normal and they just want to be even
better these people who have got you
know some kind of you know deficit in
that regard so they are very shy they
may be panic they may be have panic
attacks they stuffed a lot when they
speak and they're looking for a way to
kind of ease themselves and send a look
into these social nootropics nootropics
that work in the similar way to those
that increase focus and attention but
they're focusing on different
neurotransmitters one that can help them
be more confident less in their own
heads and get out of their own way shut
up the spine and the inner critic you
know I said they can just flow and be
really kind of engaging cool
conversation so they can become like an
alpha male or like a jock when actually
they're more of an introverted
personality type
by the way introverted doesn't
necessarily mean shy as convincing and
that's a topic I'll be covering
introduce us very interesting difference
between but anyways point is that there
are some people experimenting with this
stuff so I took a look into it does it
work like I already said an introduction
no but there are some very interesting
things I think that are worth examining
in a bit more detail so the main thing
you find people using our GABAergic s--
that sounds like nonsense gaba stands
for gamma amino butyric acid and that's
the primary inhibitory neurotransmitter
in the brain what this means is it
reduces activity between neurons it
inhibits it inhibits the firing between
the sinuses whereas something like going
to mate or acetylcholine increases the
activity in your brain this reduces
activity in your brain and that might
not sound like a very good thing but if
you're a person use of social foaming
then quietly in your brain and reducing
all that chapter is a good way to make
yourself less nervous in a sexual
situation so an example of a Gabba Gabba
urge ik is Spenny beat Benny but I don't
know how you pronounce it sound like a
fish benefit we'll call it so this is a
precursor to gather so increases the
amount of guard with your brain maybe
and that in theory quietly down allows
you to get out of your own way and to
relax and to speak more freely in theory
problem is that it's also got several
downsides for starters you're not
actually walk witty or clever or
confident you're just not thinking as
much so you basically slowed your brain
down if you wanted to be more charming
you've basically done the exact opposite
thing so you're less worried but you
also less so you like that you probably
know what it's like to have an increase
in garber in your brain because it's
what happens when you drink alcohol also
eventually it completely shuts down the
brain areas normally starting from the
front working its way back to starting
with prefrontal cortex higher order
reason
pre-planning that sort of thing so that
shuts down you lose your inhibitions you
lose your ability to think no that's not
such a good idea you start acting on
impulse so yeah it kind of makes you
modeling drunk of course it's far less
potent and alcohol but not really a
great idea if your idea if you're
hopeless to give presentations and be
much more interesting this won't do it
this will just make you less nervous and
actually worse at speaking my main
difficulty when it comes to socializing
is that my brain works a bit faster than
my mouth so this would not help me this
would be the worst thing I could take
because then I just be just slowly sway
with it so as I just mentioned penny
boot phenibut works in a similar way to
alcohol so actually a lot of us are
already using a social nootropic all the
time that's why we take alcohol isn't it
takeout course why we drink alcohol we
drink alcohol because we're in a social
setting and we feel a bit nervous and we
want to lubricate flow of conversation
we want to feel less in our own heads
and just let loose let our hair down
that's exactly the same kind of thing
but again nobody would say this isn't
gonna turn you into limitless alcohol
turns you into pretty the ring idiot but
some people do use alcohol they
self-medicate with alcohol for social
anxiety not a good idea cause there's
all sorts of other problems and killed
brain cells in the long term it can
cause korsakoff's syndrome which is
basically like outsiders that's the
opposite of a nootropic it's not a smart
drug user it's a dumb drug but again it
has this is the problem with defining
nootropics at all because they're so
varied all your different brain
activities all the different chemicals
they don't have that purpose
none of them are bad as such you need
all of them in order to be a working
optimally that's why I think increasing
one neurotransmitter or you know taking
specific
precursors is not the answer I talked
about cognitive metabolic enhancers but
you can see all about that later
something that's quite interesting that
you may have heard of is a drink called
kava or karma karma this is the root of
a plant and karma is basically a drink
that's used in Fiji during ceremonies it
says it's a social drink it's their
equivalent of alcohol and like alcohol
and like liniment
it increases garma but it does it in
in a more mild way and it also isn't and
it also works on the adrenergic
adrenergic receptors so it basically
increases the effects of adrenaline in
your body so whilst at the same time
it's sedating you and making you feel
looser more relaxed it also wakes you up
and makes you more focused and people
say it's a bit like having this kind of
calm focus where they feel relaxed
they're actually more aware of sounds
around them
and there are certain reports that it's
bad for the liver but and it's bound in
some countries it was banned in
countries like Germany in Canada but
recently they overturned them laws
having discovered that those reports
were mainly from people who already had
some kind of liver damage the point I'm
getting at in a very roundabout kind of
way is that kava is maybe a actually
safer alternative to alcohol it's an
aesthetic so it gives you an unmanned
the can make you feel nauseous
some people do say they feel not
particularly productive for next day
it's not perfect and you shouldn't drive
on it but it's kind of like car it's
kind of like alcohol but without all of
the side effects and symptoms I'm not
saying they want you to take that again
garber is not the way to increase your
social confidence it's just the way to
make you dopey but you know it's
interesting isn't it and I would supply
an interesting that some people are
thinking of banning kava makes you think
if alcohol was discovered today it would
be banned like definitely but yeah I
don't recommend using cava like I say
it's just interesting I don't use it
myself
there is a bar in New York City called
Karma Sutra so you can go and try it
legally in a safe setting if you're
interested in that and I think it's a
relatively okay thing but again not that
social nootropic it's more social
lubricant and I think there's a
definition a distinction to be made
there then you have something like five
HTTP 5-hydroxytryptophan 5-htp
is a precursor to serotonin this time
and much like tryptophan which is found
in turkey 5-htp is like a step back from
tryptophan it gets converted into
serotonin so serotonin is happiness
hormone it's one of the you know the
pleasure hormones this makes you and
it's negatively correlated with
depression so taking serotonin makes you
less stressed it makes you less
depressed and it converts eventually to
melatonin so you
good night's sleep and again it's a kind
of more relaxing rather than stimulating
neurotransmitter once again it's not
going to change you if you have social
anxiety it's not going to completely
reverse that because basically you're
just in a slightly better mood that's
not quite the same thing you're still
got the brain chatter that made you
nervous in the first place the effects
are very mild and yeah so basically I
wouldn't highly recommend that one
either basically you have the ones that
increase gaba which is very similar to
have something like a an angio lytic
such as benzodiazepines would work and
then you have something that increases
serotonin 5-htp which is basically a
much weaker version of how an
antidepressant so such an SSRI so
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor
would work so they're basically slightly
milder alternatives to anxiety
medications and depression medications
and neither those are going to turn you
into super mister confident in fact it's
probably just gonna make you feel a bit
brain foggy and phenibut in particular
and has some symptoms I think some
people find it addictive so just this is
not the answer that's that's the
conclusion this is not the answer then
you have l-theanine found in green tea
helps make me a bit more relaxed and you
have piracetam people say that taking
Brasstown can sometimes improve their
sociability and their mood
however piracetam has also been reported
to inhibit verbal fluency so make you
stutter and make it difficult for words
to come to mind so it's all different
reports whatever happens my love my love
benefit and still a tempering with
neurotransmitters Althea Nia is
perfectly safe
and I think Brasstown probably find
there are some reports of brain fog from
piracetam but still again conclusion not
the answer not going to turn you into
any more on NZT
so yeah that's not particularly
uplifting I basically said none of it
works most of it's dangerous daily
recommended don't do it not a very
positive video so far I didn't say there
are some interesting things though
and there are say one of them is
oxytocin you can take oxytocin you can
even get an oxytocin oxytocin spray
oxytocin you might be familiar with is
the love hormone and it's the one that
makes you feel an agreeable and it's
going to produce when you look at your
newborn child it's a place to be you
know well it's another feel-good hormone
but specifically about love so some
people actually take this as a kind of
way to improve their mood in their
sociability and so they get on better
with people but actually oxytocin a bit
like dopamine which everyone calls the
reward hormone it's not as clear-cut not
as straightforward as you might think
because oxytocin is produced when you
feel in love but it's also possibly
what's responsible for heartbreak and it
makes you more agreeable and more you
know likely to to agree what people say
so again you're not turning into this
kind of sharpest this could slick social
character instead you're turning into
this kind of weepy person who loves
anyone and is crying and plus an
exaggeration it wouldn't have that
strong an effect on you but you
shouldn't take it as a social nootropic
in fact it's used in another way by some
salespeople they actually have a spray
and oxytocin spray and they they wear it
and they spray it when they come around
your door-to-door and it makes you a
more agreeable so it makes them more
like to buy their products so you can
actually use this kind of United States
with nootropic it's not but you can use
it on other people in a kind of
strategic manner in that way which is
yeah I think that's interesting but yeah
you shouldn't take it yourself and I
also wouldn't say you should use it on
other people to get all you want because
that seems rather manipulative and
probably there are ethical
considerations there you're maybe I
don't know I don't know so yeah you
don't want to increase oxytocin and if
anything it's a weapon to be used
strategically but don't do it so if
that's not what you want happens if you
reduce your oxytocin then what happens
well then you turn into mania
Psychopaths there's one theory that you
could use up to Tosun to treat
psychopathy and say and it makes sense
because you become less sympathetic you
become less upset by hurting other
people you miss people less like a
psychopath and actually being a
psychopath does have its advanced
one imagines in fact studies do show
that Psychopaths actually you know the
non dangerous kind they actually
progressed better through corporate
structures because they're willing to
step in be able to get to what they want
so if you've been held back because and
I mean think about it when you're in a
social situation often II don't want to
speak up because you're worried about
offending someone or saying the wrong
thing if you're a psychopath you don't
either in care so you're happy to just
you know trample on their feelings again
not very nice this is just out of
interest because I think it's a really
interesting subject but again I do not
recommend doing it I do not advocate it
or think you should but you can suppress
York to Tosun production with a
substance called a tissa ban I believe
which is used to prevent premature labor
because a lot of oxytocin is produced
when women are in labor and this
encourages them to have the baby so they
give this to women and that prevents
them from having the baby as much and it
also reduces both doctor Tosun and
vasopressin so in theory you could take
this at tissa ban and you could become
slightly more psychopathic and that
could help me to do things you want
imagine you know using it in a kind of
scalpels in our context sensitive manner
like you you want to dump your partner
so you take some that disobey you need
to fire clive because he's always smelly
and disgusting so you you take some at
is about and then you just don't care
like again you know I would let's go no
good idea definitely moral issues but
interesting isn't it and they are saying
that would eventually be solved as a as
a nasal spray again there are other
reasons you shouldn't take even if
you're not concerned about this the
moral aspect of it it reduces
vasopressin which you may or may not
know is actually good for improving your
memory so at the same time it's becoming
the psychopath you might be damaging
your memory at the same time it's anti
labor drug so I think if you really want
to be just sniffing that it's just weird
it's not it's not something anyone's
done it's just an idea I had when I was
reading up on this I just find it really
interesting but yes it's 100% a bad idea
so yeah none of these ideas are things
you should do
they don't work they do them but I hope
you found some of that interesting but I
want to end on a bum note I'd like to
try and give you some takeaways that you
can maybe use it would maybe be helpful
for improving social skills not that I'm
mr. awesome of being social in fact I'd
say I'm naturally an introvert but I
think I come across as quite upgoing
sometimes in the right context and
that's because of stuff that I've done
so maybe I can share some tips and again
I've done a lot of reading and research
and writing on it so I've got a couple
of ideas one of them is CBT CBT is
cognitive behavioral therapy and I'm not
going to detail it on it here because
it's something I'd like to talk about
again in future videos but CBT is
basically a method for reprogramming
your own thought processes and if that
sounds like gobbledygook it's not it's
the main psychotherapeutic method
recommended by the NHS and it basically
involves looking at the thought
processes that are making you stressed
and then replacing them with much more
constructive ones and it's used mainly
for treating issues but I think it can
also be used for self improvement and
performance enhancement so in the case
of an anxiety attack
social anxiety you might be thinking
things like [ __ ] you know I'm gonna
that's probably not you thinking hey
jannat where they came from so what
you're probably thinking is more like
I'm gonna stutter I'm going to say the
wrong thing you're gonna laugh at me
it's gonna be stupid and I'm so stupid
so that's what you've got to not think
so you gonna get rid of that and see the
key with encourage you to replace that
thought with something not necessarily
you've got to believe it so you don't
just go well no I'm so amazing because
you know something to fix the problem
to fix the problem you've got to say do
I care for these people that for now I'm
giving a presentation about some
stranger's doesn't matter does it if I
have people laugh at me like I'm gonna
see them again yeah it doesn't matter
and when you actually believe that and
convince yourself and think it through
then you're fine and another strategy
and see in CBT is something called
hypothesis testing and that means that
you basically test your theory that
people are going to laugh at you because
people are really sympathetic so if you
go on the stage and you a new one and
you stutter or you say something stupid
you'll find that people don't matter you
and this is how I overcame my inability
to getting
Geir when I was at traffic lights I was
learning to drive you know I think every
learner drivers been in the situation
you at the front of the queue you wait
for the lights to go [ __ ] you trying
drive forwards and then you stall the
car
and everyone's honking behind you and
angry and I was like I know this is so
bad
but in my driving instructor he was
actually a bit of a douche but anyways
he said to me you know sit here I want
you to sit down he's sitting until the
light changes not even try and go
forward and just realize that you know
they're angry but your learner driver
they should be sympathetic it's not the
end of the world it's fine and sure I
think that was a bit of a dick move
because they won't have to wait but then
by the end of it yeah you know they
believe cushions webs in bad the worst
case no it wasn't so bad so you can
practice doing this sort of stuff out in
the real world one example of how you
could do it in your spare time is to go
into shops shop we're not going to go
there regularly because otherwise you
know you'll get a bad reputation but
going through a shop or or something
that you want to buy there do it in a
funny voice and you'll be like really
nervous at first I think [ __ ] this is
scary but actually once you do that a
couple of times you start to realize
people just kind of ignore it if you win
they're just kind of like okay here you
go sir get up my shop really fast please
but they don't say anything there's no
repercussions it doesn't matter so
there's really nothing to worry about
and so you can get away with putting on
a weird voice in a shop you can
certainly get away with stuttering or
just making small talk that's a bit
awkward and even just that just practice
doing small talk so really it's just
doing the thing that makes you feel
uncomfortable practicing it will make
you better at it and that's difference
between staying how you are and moving
forwards is just practice and facing the
things that you feel uncomfortable about
one other example of how you can use CBT
is if you are someone is prone to panic
attacks in social situations they teach
you how to overcome that CBT is very
good for that kind of thing and one of
the things I'll teach you there and when
he knows it's the fight-or-flight
response when they knows when you notice
you know your heart rate increase and
you feel that sensation of butterflies
instead of trying if they can all know
this is terrible and trying to fight it
down which actually just makes you more
stress and makes it worse instead you
think this is fine this is me on my game
because that's what's going on when
you're in the fight-or-flight response
basically your brain is producing more
adrenaline and dopamine and
norepinephrine and you're fired up and
that's a good thing
in Whittier and smarter the problem is
when you fight it and you kind of end up
working stuff up more and more to the
point where you faint and that's not
cool so instead you just guys say this
is great this is me on my game I'm
psyched even listen to some kind of
motivating music like I tweeted ambushed
some Stan Bush music and then yeah let's
do this instead of thinking oh no I'm
stressed this dress is fine it's got a
kind of go into it lean into it likewise
you can also practice other aspects of
your social game something I've been
doing is reading aloud practice because
what I struggle with as I mentioned is
you know stumbling over my words is I
figured that it's hard sometimes to find
the end the young the words that I need
to say in the situation to sound like
not stupid that's something that I've
been working on one way I do it is by
just reading aloud because you just
practice and get better at you know
letting words roll off your tongue just
do it every morning we need a passage
it's not hard another thing I'm doing at
the moment is kind of made this little
app and it'll say to me describe to me
the benefits or oranges I'm like [ __ ]
okay orange is a really orange they
stand out from distance so you're just
thinking on the spot because that's the
other aspect of social situations that I
sometimes find tricky is just being
quick-witted in general I want to be
quicker wit let's say you know quickly
thinking on the spot and coming up with
this sort of thing is really good
something that is often recommended is
practicing being a stand-up comic and
you know that's something that's you
know we terrify most people that's the
whole point it's great practice teaches
you to be a bit more immune to the kind
of fear you get from that and also at
the same time to think more on the spot
and to be more confident more of a
presenter and I actually find that doing
these videos has helped me a little bit
to present better because I've noticed
I've been trying to up my energy levels
in this video I've been watching other
videos that other people have made and
seeing how they kind of are almost
acting at the camera you know you have
to be much bigger much louder than you
would be in real life because if
something is lost in translation
otherwise so whereas I wouldn't normally
gesticulate quite so much in real life
when I'm on camera it actually helps if
I'm a bit more hey hey
cursing clown it just you know it
communicates better so that's something
else you can do you know talk
watch yourself back what other people
talk and you know did practice it's just
any other like any other skill it's just
practice and that's something that I
found helpful then there are the other
small things you can do just to feel a
bit more confident and you know on top
of the world for instance working out
just gives you a massive boost in
confidence and it changes the way that
people respond to you as well if you
take a bit more space as a guy or if
you're just in really good shape
generally yeah it gives you a big boost
not only because you you know you get
that reaction but also because you feel
more confident in yourself and you know
you kind of communicate that on an
almost unconscious level and they'll say
you just think yeah well you might have
you know insulted me the really witty
way I would come back right now but I
can tear off your head to stay you know
we'll call it a draw just you know yeah
the upper hand in some ways even if you
don't in others and also just trying to
dress a bit better you know not being
the style icon or anything like that but
just wearing clothes that make you feel
more confident makes a huge difference I
didn't think it would I was always going
for when traders and stuff lately other
type on my shoes and those jeans mature
and does make a really big difference to
the way you feel and again to the way
people react around you they just think
oh man a guy knows what what it's all
about so yeah anyways yeah this isn't
supposed to be a self-help confidence
video I'm just saying there are other
ways that are far more effective to
boost your confidence your social skills
that sort of thing as opposed to using
nootropics new trade it was interesting
but it's not the answer in that case and
the only exception I would say is if you
are going to go through something like
CBT you know so a proper therapist then
maybe you could use a garvik or
something like that to calm you down
as you subject yourself to those
situations and you get better at them so
yeah there's the uses for them but for
the average Joe I would say practice and
you know all the boring stuff it's just
like with working out isn't everyone
wants there to be some amazing someone's
gonna change everything but at the end
of the day what really works is getting
in the gym and working hard and it's the
same thing with trying to be better and
more confident and it's something that
all of us should all be working
all the time and practicing I mean it's
easy enough to practice you just got to
get out more which you know yeah I know
that sucks actually
so yeah thanks for watching I hope you
found some of that useful or interesting
or just you know whatever you didn't
hate watching it sorry about the quality
of my camera with the refocusing all the
time that is something I'm gonna replace
soon hopefully with some Christmas money
I'll get myself a nice better quality
camera I'm constantly trying to work on
you know the production values of my
videos and the presentation and
hopefully you've seen an improvement at
least since the old days it's hard to
get any worse
I really appreciate any of you stuck
with me you know if you you know watch
regularly thanks very much